rot grüner jubel in hamburg die
amtierende koalition kann weiterregieren
die afg ist nach ersten prognosen raus
kampf gegen korona um das virus
einzudämmen regelt italien ganze städte
im norden des landes ab und sturm über
deutschland wegen heftiger winde müssen
mehrere karnevalsumzüge abgesagt werden
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und ein
herzliches willkommen an diesem
wahlsonntag norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei für den sport
wundern darf von mir die erste
landtagswahl nach dem debakel in
thüringen bringt eine überraschung die
afg fliegt wohl aus der bürgerschaft
abgesehen davon haben sich die hamburger
wähler wie erwartet für ein weiter so
entschieden also weiter rot grün die cdu
ist weit abgeschlagen und die fdp muss
um den einzug in die bürgerschaft
zittern
matthias fornoff in unserem wald studio
in hamburg hat jetzt die neuesten zahlen
matthias guten abend wir schauen uns die
zahlen noch einmal an
da sehen wir die spd käme demnach auf 38
prozent zwar mit deutlichen verlusten
aber stärkste partei die cdu elf prozent
mit klaren verlusten die gründen mehr
als verdoppelt 25,5 prozent
zweitstärkste kraft die linke verbessert
9,5 prozent die fdp auf der kippe bei 5
das kann doch klappen mit dem einzug
oder auch nicht und die afg er unterhalb
der fünf-prozent-hürde so sehen wir das
im moment man muss dazu sagen
dies ist eine prognose hamburg hat ein
kompliziertes wahlsystem das auszählen
der stimmen dauert lang deshalb gibt es
noch keine hochrechnungen tatsächlich
ausgezählten zahlen was heißt das für
die verteilung der sitze in der
hamburger bürgerschaft die spd 51 sitze
die cdu 15 grüne 35 linke 13 und die fdp
wenn sie den sprung schafft sieben sitze
die absolute mehrheit liegt bei 61
sitzen jetzt schauen wir mal
welches koalitionsmodell das erreichen
könnte und diese linie hier
überschreitet die amtierende rot-grüne
koalition sehr deutlich 86 sitze eine
koalition von spd und cdu würde es auch
schaffen nicht ganz so deutlich aber
klar und jamaica falls die fdp denn drin
ist grüne cdu fdp würde dir 61 sitze
verpassen
das bisherige ergebnis zeigt ja dass die
hamburger offenbar durchaus zufrieden
sind mit ihrer regierung da ist wenig
lust auf wechsel ja sowohl rot als auch
grüne spd und grüne sind sehr positiv
für ihre arbeit bewertet worden und man
muss
so sagen die oppositionsparteien waren
hier nicht auf augenhöhe wir schauen uns
nochmal eine grafik an die sehr
eindrucksvoll ist 61 prozent der
wählerinnen und wähler in hamburg
wünschen sich dass rot-grün fortgesetzt
wird dass es ein sehr ungewöhnlich hoher
wert und noch einmal bezogen auf die afd
wenn sie tatsächlich nicht in die
bürgerschaft käme wäre das zum ersten
mal seit 2003 10 der hessen landtagswahl
danke für diese informationen aus
hamburg matthias v die hamburger
bestätigen also mit großer deutlichkeit
ihre regierung die derzeit einzige rot
grüne landesregierung in deutschland und
die spd kann seit langem mal wieder
einen wahlabend feiern bettina schausten
hat jetzt die spitzenkandidaten bei sich
mit dem vermutlich entsprechend gelösten
spd frontmann peter tschentscher bettina
ja so ist es alle sind hier versammelt
also alle die über die fünf prozent
hürde in der prognose es geschafft haben
und wir beginnen bei peter tschentscher
den wir kurz vor dieser sendung schon
sprechen konnten und er hat angekündigt
dass er auch mit der cdu reden wird aber
wenn man sich auch die analysedaten
gerade anschaut der checker können sie
den hamburgern heute abend nicht doch
versichern müssen sie ihn gerade zu
versichern dass es mit rot grün weiter
geht wir haben immer gesagt dass
rot-grün die naheliegende option ist das
gilt auch jetzt wir werden als erstes
auch mit den grünen sprechen sondieren
für mich ist ja wichtig dass wir einen
koalitionsvertrag zustande bekommen bei
dem die richtigen projekte und ziele für
unsere stadt festgelegt werden und das
werden die nächsten tage und wochen
zeigen wie wir das am besten hinbekommen
ich sage eindeutig rot grün hat
erfolgreiche arbeit gemacht und ihre
zahlen zeigen ja auch das ist eine große
unterstützung gibt diese koalition
katharina fegebank sie wollten
eigentlich grün rot das hat nicht
geklappt jetzt müssen sie mit herrn
tschentscher vermutlich wieder rot grün
machen wie groß ist denn die lust ist
jedoch relativ viel porzellan
zerschlagen worden in den letzten wochen
ja aber wir haben sehr erfolgreiche
koalition gehabt die letzten fünf jahre
und ich sehe nicht warum das nicht
wieder funktionieren sollte mit einem
deutlich stärkeren votum für die grünen
ich begreife das jedenfalls als klaren
wählerauftrag hier aus hamburg weiter
rot grün mit starken grünen in der
regierung in wenigen worten welche
grünen akzente wollen sie setzen
konsequenter klimaschutz echte
verkehrswende offene gesellschaft und
strukturwandel hin zu einer wissens- und
innovations- metropole
die bundes-cdu hat ihnen das wurde heute
abend bestätigt wenig rückenwind gegeben
markus wallenberg esther spitzenkandidat
der cdu hamburg aber der weinberg das
ist ja schon auch ein hausgemachtes
hamburger ergebnis ein negativrekord für
die cdu hier
welche konsequenzen ziehen sie daraus
jetzt wieder mehrere faktoren die
gewirkt haben das ist tatsächlich
thüringen und die folgewirkung die
massiv für uns den letzten wochen noch
mal als wahlkämpfer irritiert haben
natürlich ist so dass wir als cdu und
großstädten seit jahren probleme haben
gewisse milieus zu erreichen
und natürlich der hamburger besonderheit
die viele wechselstimmung und das
konzentrierte beachten der fragestellung
wie sie ist oder er das natürlich von
der oppositionspartei eine sehr
schwierige ausgangssituation aber der
orkan der letzten wochen aus thüringen
der hat es dann wirklich noch mal ganz
schön durchgerüttelt angesichts dieser
schlappe würden sie überhaupt sich
anbieten wollen sie hatten sind der
haben auch die mut und sollten mit blick
auf das wahlergebnis sicher
zurückhaltend was wir aber ganz klar
sagen ist wir schließen es nicht aus und
es gibt eine fragestellung die sich
hamburg in wichtigen feldern weiter
entwickelte von der wirtschaft zur
infrastruktur und auch mit blick auf die
neuen themen der stadt und deswegen
sagen wir ganz deutlich wir stehen
bereit zu gesprächen aber der ball liegt
nicht in unserem feld sondern im feld
für des ersten bürgermeisters und das
glaube ich ist die richtige ausgangslage
frau ist sie mir die linken haben
zugelegt in hamburg worauf führen sie
das zurück sie stehen ja in hamburg sehr
für das soziale
sie schauen in die ecken von hamburg wo
die anderen parteien nicht so sehr hin
zu schauen hat das
bei ihnen auch beim wähler funktioniert
ja ich denke in den letzten jahren haben
die menschen ja auch ganz deutlich
gesehen dass wir eben auch themen
ansprechen die von anderen parteien
nicht mehr angesprochen werden auch
dahin gucken wo viele nicht mehr
hingucken und das sind dann zum beispiel
die menschen die von armut betroffen
sind die in ihren stadtteilen auch von
resignation betroffen sind aber auch von
mieterinnen und mietern die merken dass
sie ihre miete nicht mehr zahlen können
dass er war für uns ja auch das thema
mieten der präsident im wahlkampf aber
ein anderer wichtiger punkt ist
natürlich auch das ja gerade parteien
die eher links verordnet werden in
diesem wahlkampf ja auch stärker
unterstützt wurden und dass an den
ergebnissen auch deutlich ist und ich
denke es hat auch was mit hanau und
thüringen zu tun
die fdp ist hier auf der kippe in der
prognose bei 5 anna von treuenfels sie
müssen also tatsächlich heute abend noch
bangen
mal die erste analyse abgefragt bekommen
sie hier heute die quittung für
thüringen ja das glaube ich wirklich
mehrere gründe erstmals ist ja schon
angesprochen werden wir haben hier ein
kopf an kopf rennen gehabt das ist ja
auch sehr erfolgreich gewesen
bei den sehr medialen aufmerksamkeit da
war es für uns kleinere parteien
wirklich erheblich schwerer überhaupt in
so mediale präsenz zu kommen und
überhaupt auch mit themen diskutieren zu
können und dann kommt thüringen als das
rennen bei denen man fast entschieden
war dann kam thüringen das ist eine
schwere hypothek für uns gewesen weil es
natürlich auch ein vertrauensvolles bei
den bürgern gewesen ist kann ich auch
verstehen
jetzt geht es darum das vertrauen wieder
zu gewinnen als wir die ihre aufgabe
sein der abend ist noch lang das
endgültige ergebnis womöglich auch erst
morgen letzte frage an peter
tschentscher ein ergebnis für die spd
gegen den bundestrend war das heute
abend haben sie noch irgend einen
ratschlag ein tipp für berlin was können
die von ihnen lernen
ich erwarte morgen einen blumenstrauß
wie wurde angekündigt dass wir einmal
gemeinsam uns freuen morgen und dann
werden wir weiter sehen es gibt ja
wirklich unsere hamburger politik die
eine eigenständige kraft hier in der
stadt auch ist und im bund sind viele
andere themen wichtig und ich gehe davon
aus dass wir auch im bund wieder nach
vorne kommen mit den themen die unsere
bundesspitze jetzt an geht und ich ahne
um den blumenstrauß kommen sie gar nicht
drum herum so damit jetzt zurück aus
hamburg nach mainz
schön an die runde nach hamburg einmal
gemeinsam freuen das passiert und was
hamburg ist nicht nur die erste
landtagswahl nach dem politischen chaos
in thüringen
es ist auch die erste nach dem
angekündigten rückzug von annegret
kramp-karrenbauer als cdu chefin und die
erste unter der neuen spd-führung
entsprechend groß die spannung im
politischen berlin hier die reaktionen
ich glaube das tut erst mal allen gut
und natürlich sind wir uns auch alle
einig dass der weg der hier sehr auch
sichtbar wird einer ist der für uns alle
gemeinsam gelten kann und mit dem wir
stark werden können die spd muss bereit
sein um die führung zu kämpfen auch im
land in deutschland und das ist auch
möglich
es ist ein fantastisches wahlergebnis
ist das zweitbeste wahlergebnis der
grünen geschichte nur getoppt durch
winfried kretschmanns wiederwahl damals
in baden württemberg also da können die
hamburgerin sehr stolz darauf sein über
dieses ergebnis das haben sie toll
gemacht ich will gleich auf den punkt
kommen und nicht drum herum reden es ist
ein bitterer tag für die cdu
deutschlands es ist ein historisches
historisch schlechtes wahlergebnis für
die cdu in hamburg und daran gibt es
nichts schönzureden
dieser wahlkampf war von anfang an eher
angelegt und inszeniert als ein kopf an
kopf rennen zwischen spd und grünen das
ist eine situation wo es für eine partei
wie die linke dann immer schwierig wird
und wir können sagen trotz dieses kopf
an kopf rennens über lange phasen des
wahlkampfes haben wir als linke
prozentual zugelegt ich sehe hier in
hamburg natürlich insgesamt bei dem
konservativ bürgerlichen parteien einen
großen verlust wir werden wie gesagt
sehen ob das diesen abend bei uns anhält
ich denke wir kommen noch über die fünf
prozent hürde und dann in die
bürgerschaft einziehen
das ist für die freien demokraten eine
niederlage ein solches wahlergebnis die
in hamburg zu erzielen wir haben uns
dort mehr erhofft
jetzt wird das für uns einen wahlabend
sein bei dem wir wieder starke nerven
brauchen weil nicht sicher ist ob wir
der nächsten bürgerschaft angehören
oder nicht unmittelbar nach uns geht es
weiter mit den kollegen im hamburger
wahlstudio um viertel vor zehn
informiert sie das heute journal und
online hält sie natürlich unser live
blog auf heute.de den ganzen abend auf
dem laufenden
es gab auch noch andere themen ganze
dörfer und städte abgeriegelt dieses
vorgehen chinas gegen das corona virus
schien bislang weit weg nun weiß ich
aber auch in italien offenbar nur so zu
helfen
angesichts von drei toten und mehr als
130 infizierten wurden in der
norditalienischen lombardei zehn
gemeinden und im angrenzenden venetien
eine stadt unter quarantäne gestellt im
zentrum der epidemie
die kleinstadt cordonnier südöstlich von
mailand andreas post berichtet niemand
darf rein niemand darf raus tonio in der
lombardei ist abgeriegelt seitdem die
angst vor dem corona virus um sich
greift es gibt eine anweisung der
gemeinde dass alle geschäfte geschlossen
werden müssen
da ist viel alarmismus und das besonders
insgesamt elf städte und gemeinden mit
über 50.000 menschen sind betroffen
das ist bislang nicht gelungen den
ersten infizierten ausfindig zu machen
solange wir nicht modifiziert haben ist
es schwer den verbreitungsweg
nachzuvollziehen
neben einem strikten ein und ausreise
verbot greift die teils regierung zu
strengen maßnahmen um die ausbreitung
des virus einzuschränken
es wurde angeordnet dass in den
betroffenen regionen jede form der
arbeit öffentliche veranstaltungen
verschiedene öffentliche ereignisse
untersagt sind
und die schulen bis auf weiteres
geschlossen werden
dass die hochschulen in der
norditalienischen metropole mailand sind
davon betroffen
atemschutz stadt venezianische maske der
präsident der region venetien teilte im
laufe des tages mit taste berühmte
karneval in venedig vorzeitig
abgebrochen wird die auswirkungen für
wirtschaft und tourismus sind noch nicht
absehbar
wir bleiben beim corona virus iran
beklagt inzwischen acht tote die
staatsführung spricht sogar von
auswirkungen auf die gestrige
parlamentswahl unter anderem die angst
vor dem corona virus habe zu einem
rekordtief von rund 42 prozent bei der
wahlbeteiligung geführt so irans
geistliches oberhaupt ajatollah khamenei
nach ersten auszählungen liegen die
konservativen hardliner klar vorn
viele anhänger der reformen
boykottierten allerdings die wahl und
dann erschütterten heute mehrere
erdbeben den nordwesten des iran im
grenzgebiet zur türkei
die stöße mit einer stärke von bis zu
6,0 kosteten auf türkischer seite
mindestens acht menschen das leben
auf beiden seiten der grenze gab es
offenbar auch dutzende verletzte als in
mehreren dörfern des dünn besiedelten
gebietes häuser einstürzten
in die usa im bundesstaat nevada hat
bernie sanders die dritte vorwahl der
demokraten gewonnen
der linke senator aus vermont lag laut
ersten ergebnissen mit über 40 prozent
der stimmen deutlich vor ex
vizepräsident joe biden an dritter
stelle landete der ehemalige
bürgermeister aus indiana pit budde cic
nachdem rechts terroristischen anschlag
in hanau mit elf toten zeigten auch
heute wieder viele menschen in der
hessischen stadt ihre anteilnahme
mehr als zehntausend menschen nahmen an
einem schweigemarsch zum gedenken an die
opfer teil
begleitet von demonstrationen für
toleranz und multikulturelles
zusammenleben und gegen rassismus
die blicke der narren und jecken
richteten sich heute bank zum himmel
denn sturmtief julia wirbelte den
straßenkarneval buchstäblich
durcheinander
viele umzüge wurden aus
sicherheitsgründen abgesagt auch köln
und düsseldorf waren betroffen
thaddäus parade berichtet die
düsseldorfer königsallee traditionell
tummeln sich hier am karnevalssonntag
zehntausende jecken heute gähnende leere
bis auf ein paar hartgesottene wegen
schwerer sturmböen wurde das beliebte
guthaben zum ersten mal in seiner
geschichte abgesagt das ist eigentlich
unsere anarchische veranstaltung da
kommen familien mit kindern oma opa
gruppen clubs einfach karneval in der
urform zelebrieren
und das muss man leider heute absagen
schade auch in köln machte der schwere
sturm den jecken einen strich durch die
rechnung
bis zuletzt hatten die veranstalter
gehofft die beliebten umzüge in den
stadtvierteln durchführen zu können
dann aber kann es auch hier kurzfristig
zur absage bäume umgefallen
wandverkleidungen sind fliegen gegangen
auch rechts und links vom zug weg und
wir haben uns dann nach rücksprache mit
der stadt köln gemeinsam mit der stadt
köln entschieden den zug abzubrechen
trotz stark wind und dauerregen echte
jecken lassen sich den spaß nicht
verderben
morgen sollen wind und regen deutlich
abnehmen die großen rosenmontagszüge mit
karnevalshochburgen sind laut prognosen
der meteorologen nicht gefährdet wohl
dem der für seine veranstaltungen ein
dach über dem kopf hat zum beispiel
kinosäle wie auf der berlinale
heute geht der erste deutsche film ins
rennen um den goldenen bären und diene
heißt das neue werk von regisseur
christian petzold stephan merseburger
hat sich für uns angeschaut
und dean ist sein fünfter anlauf den
goldenen bären zu holen
christian petzold stammgast auf der
berlinale auch das team ist vertraut
denn seine hauptdarsteller paul baehr
und franz rogowski spielen zum zweiten
mal zusammen in einem petzold film
aufregend also ich habe den film schon
gesehen und trotzdem weiß man nicht wie
kommt er jetzt gleich an und ihnen jetzt
hier so groß zu sehen mit so viel hatten
schon aufbringt und diene ist eine figur
aus der sagenwelt ein wassergeist
petzolds und diene ist historikerin
sie arbeitet als museumsführerin im
stadtmuseum die story spielt im heutigen
berlin
sie trifft industrie taucher christoph
die anziehungskraft zwischen beiden ist
enorm und diene ist glücklich doch der
mythos lastet auf ihr sie wurde kurz
zuvor von johannes für eine andere
verlassen hat also muss udine den ex
töten und ins wasser zurückkehren
ich mochte die idee daran dass undine ja
im grunde serienmörderin ist die aber
auch schon unendlich lang ist also die
fans schon seit 600 jahren in dieser
stadt umher geistert und dementsprechend
auch alles über die stadt weiß dass
besagtes du mich liebst
für immer
und diene eine zdf koproduktion ist eine
mythische liebesgeschichte ein modernes
märchen eine art märchen wurde heute
auch in altenberg war zu sehen nicht ein
stück sportgeschichte bei der bob
allerdings und zwar geschrieben von
francesco friedrich der olympiasieger
aus sachsen
der hat heute zusammen mit thorsten mag
es nicht nur gold im zweierbob gewonnen
sondern holte zum sechsten mal
nacheinander den titel im kleinen
schlitten und das ist ein historischer
rekord am ziel seiner träume francesco
friedrich umjubelter rekordweltmeister
im zweierbob mit einem starken
anschieber thorsten magisch wir haben
alles für diesen moment getan haben uns
super vorbereitet heute war das wetter
leider nicht so sonst werden heute noch
mal richtig schnell unterwegs gewesen
aber ansonsten war alles perfekt hier
diese woche
bestzeit fuhr er auch in den verregneten
beiden heutigen läufen am ende hatte
friedrich den riesigen vorsprung von 16
5 sekunden auf seinen teamgefährten
johannes lochner dritter der lette
keeper mannes nächstes wochenende will
friedrich zum dritten mal weltmeister im
vierer werden keine medaille für die
deutschen biathleten in den massenstart
wettbewerben zum wm-abschluss in antholz
fünftes gold dagegen für die
norwegerinnen martinsspiel reiseland in
allen sieben wettbewerben holt sie eine
medaille
denise herrmann nutzt die schnellste
laufzeit nicht sie wird mit sieben
schießfehlern zwölfte beste dsv-läuferin
franziska preuß als achte und bei den
männern triumphiert der norweger
johannes dinkelsbühl bester deutscher
johannes kühn als zehnter tyson fury ist
wieder boxweltmeister eine
eindrucksvolle rückkehr auf den
schwergewichts drohen
der 31 jahre alte brite gewann in las
vegas vor 17.000 zuschauern gegen
titelverteidiger die rider aus den usa
durch technischen ko in der siebten
runde und ist neuer wbc-champion für
viele war es der dreißigste sieg im 31
kampf
und im ersten sonntagsspiel der fußball
bundesliga gewinnt leverkusen gegen
augsburg bezahlt
ich bin immer noch bei der sieges pose
des box man ist an deutlichkeit nicht zu
überbieten
das wetter bleibt ungemütlich zunächst
regnet es in der südwesthälfte später in
der mitte und im nordwesten im süden
wird es am nachmittag freundlicher zum
abend gibt es im nordwesten stürmische
böen im norden und osten 5 bis 9 grad
sonst 9 bis 18 grad
die kommenden tage werden windig und
nass der dienstag noch relativ mild 6
bis 13 grad ab mittwoch deutlich kälter
das war es von uns wir sagen es wünschen
ihnen noch einen schönen abend